foreign
let's go out to the 806 to Amarillo by
Morning and talk to Jack what's up Jack
hey Dr John how you doing I'm I'm doing
better than I deserve well dude we are
partying man I'm doing about what I
deserve I'm just kidding I'm doing great
doing great what's up
I'm well I'll I'll just uh go right into
my question but uh basically to give you
a summary
um yesterday I thought that my marriage
was over and uh that uh my wife was
going to be leaving me
um I'll go ahead and read my question
that I sent over to you guys
um my wife has decided that she is done
with our marriage and wants a divorce I
have I have asked if she wants to try
couples counseling to try and save our
marriage and she said no
she explained that from the beginning
she felt like she had to hide who she
was from me or I would leave her and not
love her
after seven years of hiding she tried
she is tired of pretending and wants to
be free to be herself
I never knew she felt this way or that
she was hiding her true feelings from me
what do I do now
and um there's a couple of updates on
that but uh I'll I'll leave it there and
you can yeah give me the updates in
there
um so I uh of course that was let me
tell us before you give me the updates I
don't buy that letter
okay um and I'll tell you why I mean I I
don't buy her her
um
yeah I don't buy it but keep going
okay absolutely
um so the updates that was that was
Monday night and so yesterday I I
thought we were done uh yesterday
evening I talked to her again
um and she
she does want to try counseling and um i
i s I think what has happened what she
what I think she was communicating to me
is that
she was trying to hide who she really
was because she was afraid
I wouldn't
love her and then she was trying to
leave because she was afraid I would
leave her when I found out who she
really was does that make sense
absolutely and sometimes sometimes
there's a lot of what I would call
fantasy talk there's a lot like she's
probably been having that imaginary
conversation in her mind for a long time
right and there's something about saying
it out loud
when you hear it come out of your mouth
you realize on its face it doesn't make
any sense
I'm so scared you're going to leave me
so I'm Gonna Leave You that doesn't make
any sense but inside your body it does
right because your body's telling you to
run run run and
um because he's about to reject you
don't let him do it you get out of here
first right so yeah that makes total
sense
um the thing that I balk at
um is the quote unquote you don't know
the real me you don't know the real me
and I can't be me
I don't have any use for that unless
somebody has sat down and said hey I
haven't been honest with you
here's what I'm into here's what I think
is funny here's what I need from you and
then you as husband get to say I'm out
on that
now we can talk about I'm having to hide
but people who just bail because you
don't know the real me I just don't buy
that it's almost always a contextual
excuse for
I am starting to not like the way I feel
in the life that I'm co-creating I want
out
does that make sense okay that does make
sense and she did share some of the
things that she felt like she was hiding
okay
um and I I I have her blessing to share
those with you if that's all right yeah
go for it okay
um so the
kind of the antithesis of this is i i
two weeks ago I caught her crying
um and she explained that she was
feeling unfulfilled in our marriage and
the life that we've built together
um we have we have the life of you know
we have a house we we both have
full-time careers we have a daughter
um and she was feeling unfulfilled in
that marriage in that life
um and she felt like she had built our
relationship on a lie
um because when we met
um
I I had never she was my
when we met I was a virgin okay and she
told me the same thing that she was as
well okay
so what she was hiding from me was that
she had actually had a few
um casual romantic Partners in the past
okay
so this is that has nothing to do with
virginity this has to do with
she knows that she married a guy with a
particular value and she lied
and she's never been able to walk on
firm foundation not because of the
actual action itself but because she
knows she didn't tell you the truth and
that has haunted her for whatever reason
it's haunted her her entire marriage
right yeah
so her saying that out loud did you run
for the hills and say get out
no absolutely not was she did she have
some sort of cathartic did she feel
better after she said
um
if I had to analyze the situation I
would it looked as though she had let go
of a burden that she was holding on to
for a long time I imagine yeah yeah
uh she didn't exactly say anything that
she you know felt better or that she
she didn't really say anything she just
she did feel
lighter if that makes sense
absolutely man
um
it's not a coincidence that she came
back a couple days later
and
said hey I want to try to work this out
I don't think
because my pushback my answer to someone
who all who says I don't like the life
I've built with so and so
I don't like the life we've built
together
I a hundred percent I've been there
myself in my marriage multiple times
the catch is you can build something
else
absolutely right you can build something
completely different is it going to be
awkward yes is it going to be weird for
sure are you gonna have to get new
friends and like the old Seinfeld you
have to get lava lamps and you're gonna
have to well I don't know what your
thing is but you can build anything new
you just got to put the work in you
gotta go get the professional help you
need to learn new skills to go do what
you gotta do but this idea that is just
run its course or the idea that I don't
like what we've built cool been there
build something else
absolutely and the Imp the impulse is
just a bail and run and what she did I'm
actually proud of her that would have
haunted her forever she wouldn't have
gotten the relief that she thought she
was going to get by being out of this
relationship with you and if I'm you
brother there's probably more coming
oh yes I've I've been preparing myself
and I've also been trying to share
things with her that I haven't been
completely honest about and I can share
those with you if we would like to get
into that bring it on man yeah
absolutely
um and and you you had asked if I ran
for the hills I I did tell her that I
want to build a new life together it's
awesome good for you that is that is
almost Verbatim what I told her because
I still love her
and I love the the new her that I'm
meeting I love her more than I ever have
I I know that maybe that's not relevant
but no it for sure is because she took
she took a chance she took a risk
yeah and her body had told her if you
tell him the truth he's done he's out of
here
and not only were you not out of there
but you leaned in you got closer
I also want to say Jack
when y'all go see a counselor together
it's okay to
be sad that she lied to you for all
these years that's okay
yeah it's all right it's a there's a
weird thing like let's say somebody was
sexually abused as a kid and they don't
tell their spouse and then year 10 comes
along and they tell their spouse
there's this dual compassion like oh my
gosh I can't believe you were hurt like
that
um I love you and then there's also the
what was it about me that I wasn't safe
enough to tell right that's a normal
reaction
and so
um
it's it's not a
it's not normal to keep those things
inside not talk about them but it's also
all those all those feelings are normal
you're not crazy okay but right now it
feels like the whole thing there's a
relief there
um what did you feel like you needed
needed to contribute
oh um so while while she was sharing her
her past with me
um I explained to her that I had been
hiding something from her as well and
what I was hiding was a porn addiction
um and she when I when I told her that
she's actually the first person I've
ever told and you are the second person
luckily it's just me and you man yeah
right it's just millions of people
nobody listens to this show dude so
you're you're safe with me you're safe
well thank you if I told my wife and a
million people um and a million people
yup can I how long has that been going
on before you were married
uh uh yes I I would say I found access
to that kind of stuff around age 12 if
I'm remembering correctly
um it is not uncommon
uh well I won't go down that road I'm
glad you told her man
and she felt that disconnection you felt
her disconnection and y'all been about
solving it in whatever ways your bodies
could solve it
so she's not here so I can just ask ask
you what are you gonna do man are you
gonna go to uh an essay meeting once a
week are you gonna go to
um meet with your group of guy like what
are you gonna do
um
what I'm gonna do is uh I I've asked her
what practices we would like to put into
place and uh if and I've told her she
can ask me any questions that she wants
to
um she's still she's still thinking
about it and processing it I want you to
come to her with a plan because what you
just did was you put it
kind of halfway on her
I want you to come with a plan is here's
what I'm going to do
anything you need to do to feel safe in
this relationship or to rebuild trust
I'm in
gotcha and vice versa you held a lie
about joint values that we shared for
seven years plus
all the time we dated so almost a decade
um
I may over the next five or ten years
ask you more questions I may want to
learn more about that and that's not me
being gratuitous that is me
um learning about my wife because now a
whole new Portal's been opened
yeah right and that's just part of
learning and getting to know each other
absolutely
so yeah
um did you have like a specific question
I can help you with I think it sounds
like you're on the right track man
that's not go find it go find a good
marriage counselor and y'all lean in and
commit I think the biggest commitment
you make right now is not how we're
going to solve all these things but our
commitment is I will tell you the truth
no matter what we are a couple that
tells each other the truth we are a
couple that
under penalty of law and penalty of
death we will tell each other what we
need in the moment in the day and in the
month
I'm not gonna hide that anymore right
and you Brothers You've got to go get
help for a long long term addiction
yes absolutely
um I I have to say I think
when when I sent the question yesterday
the the what do I do now was kind of uh
you know do I respect your wishes do I
do I let her go do I file first
um because I I wanna I want to respect
her wishes and do
um
do what she needs to be happy but with
this new information I feel like
um
I feel like the answer is just to keep
keep fighting for her keep fighting I
would I'm not a fan at all of what I
call the bailout file
it's very very common that somebody
comes in and says I'm not happy in this
marriage we've built together I'm not
happy in this I'm not happy in this
you've been doing this you don't do this
I want a divorce
then they just sit there for months
and so if you want to leave me and and
so often
um man guys leave the house women leave
the bed and go sleep in the guest room
bro if you're leaving me you can do that
but this is my house this is my bed
if you want a divorce from me great you
file the paperwork
I'm not a fan of the I'll I'll do the
dirty work for you
it's kind of like that Michael Scott
like I declare bankruptcy like that's
not how that works right right
um you can't just announce to somebody I
don't like the life we've built together
so I'm out uh you go file so I can tell
everybody that he filed on me
so that I can tell everybody that he did
this and then in five years it's gonna
be kind of a Blind Side Story right I'm
not doing that
you're welcome to not sleep in my bed or
our bed it breaks my heart but you're
welcome to do that I'm not leaving
okay right so
um and some of that is this
um I've I've walked several people who I
love through messiness in this area over
the last couple years
there's this idea this feeling that when
I file divorce when we get divorced my
life will be exactly as it is now just
not with you in it
and probably some sort of replacement
vehicle for you
I'll still be in this house I'll still
be in this bed I'll still go to the same
Supermarket our kids relationship will
still be like this
um we're gonna have this fantasy
co-parenting relationship and then I can
have the man of my dreams it's going to
make me all feel great and good and
wonderful
and I am of the impression that um I
call them micro doses but not the
psilocybin kind micro doses of
you have to understand if you file for
divorce we got a kid we have a life
you're blowing up everything there is no
Plug and Play here
and so if you want out you can be out
if you say hey we're just going to start
practicing this we're going to do kids
on Tuesday Thursday here and I'll take
them on Monday Wednesday Friday and then
that very next week it's like well hey I
I'm not doing that not doing that
like we're gonna we're gonna I'm gonna
be an adult you're gonna be an adult
you want to destroy everything and burn
this thing to the ground you're like
you're able to do that in modern America
I'm not participating in that I'm not
gonna be a jerk I'm not going to be rude
I'm not going to hold things up I'm not
going to be like never I'm not gonna be
a stalker
but I'm asleep in my bed that makes
sense
absolutely and I know I'm gonna get some
pushback on that I don't care
um the other thing is this
um
I would
I would begin to lean in and I know I
say this like a broken record on this
show I would make it a practice every
day of your life to wake up and look
your wife in the eye hold both of her
hands and say how can I love you today
and if she says I don't know I don't I
don't know I don't
just say give me one thing
and begin to lean into it that way
because what y'all gonna have to rebuild
is not some tactics and strategies
you're gonna have to rebuild the
foundation of this plane because the
foundation's it's fell over right it
fell over she told you this you told her
this y'all been keeping things from each
other
um you both have been in systematic
dishonesty with one another
all right let's rebuild it we're both in
it I do love you she loves you we're
gonna rebuild this thing from the floor
up and we're gonna start with connection
we're gonna start with telling the truth
we're going to start with how can I love
you I'm gonna go first servant
servanthood right we're gonna go that
way we're not gonna go with I get to
look at your phone and I get to ask you
all the questions about your old
boyfriends that I would have asked you
like that's not where we're going to
start we might go we might get there
that's done where we're gonna start
we're gonna start with connection with
love thanks for the call my brother
um dude call anytime I appreciate your
vulnerability and you being open
um
be a couple that always tells the truth
be a couple that says their needs out
loud